c'est ici que commence mon voyage sous
la pluie en pleine forêt d'amazonie à
contempler la terre et les hommes qui se
donnent en spectacle
dans cette région longtemps délaissé un
jour des pionniers sont venus chacun
avec leurs rêves
chacun avec leur utopie pour tenter leur
chance et faire fortune
ils se sont approprié la terre pour
l'exploiter
ce sont eux que je veux rencontrer de la
forêt à la côte jusqu'à são luis
un voyage de près de 1000 km à travers
les état du para et du maragnon en plein
far west
pour l'heure on voyage commence sur la
mine de karadj as la plus grande mine de
fer au monde un trou dans lequel on a
vite les pieds dans la boue
la mine de karadj as une fourmilière des
temps modernes surtout des monstres
hurlant qu'ils chargent et déchargent
près de 100 millions de tonnes de fer
par an et les petits hommes aux
commandes
[Musique]
changement d'équipage
l'un des camionneurs se propose de me
déposer à la gare pour que je poursuive
mon voyage
un étage pour les roues un autre pour le
radiateur
bienvenue à bord du plus gros camion du
monde antonio dutra 35 ans se décide à
me donner la conversation comme le
ferait un chauffeur de taxi à paris
[Musique]
quand j'étais gamin j'adorais les
petites voitures et des camions
miniatures ont joué avant de travailler
ici j'avais jamais approché de vrai
camion alors tu comprends avoir la
chance de pouvoir en conduire un en
vérité c'est plus qu'un rêve
c'est un défi pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand on conduit la nuit il arrive assez
souvent quand on tombe nez à nez avec un
animal sauvage un cerf ou un tapir c'est
vraiment l'une des situations qui
m'étonne le plus quand on travaille ici
sur la mine
moi ce qui m'étonne le plus c'est qu'au
milieu de la forêt depuis toujours par
tomber sur l'empreinte des hommes la
gare le faire ils tombent du ciel on
l'acheminera en train jusqu'à la mer
pour alimenter le monde
je décide de grimper à bord
[Musique]
trois kilomètres de long 334 wagon 110
tonnes chacun le plus long et lourd
train jamais inventée et à son bord un
seul chauffeur mais qui se veut
rassurant
c'est con
le transport ferroviaire au brésil c'est
sûr à 98% et les 2 % qui restent alors
moi c'est moi ça dépend de mon attention
parce que je suis un être humain
[Musique]
mais je me sens très privilégié de
conduire les trains j'en avais jamais
vus auparavant en suisse ça me donne
l'inspiration pour écrire je regarde pas
c'est la vie et quand le train s'arrête
je me mets à écrire je travaille en
faisant des choses que j'aime ça c'est
un poème que j'ai écrit en mémoire d'un
châtaignier qui existait un peu plus
loin et qui a cessé de vivre
les hommes ont des faux restait le
secteur en laissant l'arbre tout seul
mais petit à petit la mort l'a rattrapé
quand il était sur le point de tomber la
foudre l'a cassé en deux
[Musique]
non mes poèmes je demande aux hommes de
s'arrêter et réfléchir parce que si ça
continue comme ça un jour nous aussi on
va cesser d'exister
[Musique]
en attendant que les hommes
réfléchissent les wagons chargés de
minerais continuent de défiler mais moi
j'ai décidé de faire escale au village
de serra pelada dans les années 80 des
chercheurs d'or se sont rués ici par
dizaines de milliers dans l'espoir de
faire fortune certains sont repartis les
bras chargés de pépites
d'autres se sont résignés à vivre là ne
trouvant au fond des trous que le reflet
de leurs illusions perdues
un jour le gouvernement a décidé de tout
réglementer et depuis quelques mois des
hommes casqués s'activent au nez à la
barbe des villageois la rumeur dit qu'il
travaille pour les exploitants de la
mine de fer de karadj à ce faire or même
combat il y aurait à serra pelada
l'équivalent d'un milliard et demi de
dollars en or pur encore enfouis sous la
terre
malgré les interdictions certains gars
et mme perreault continue à creuser chez
eux sous leur cuisine c'est le cas de
chico qui m'invite à le suivre au fond
du trou
parce qu'on est plus tranquille pour
parler
[Musique]
90 mètres de profondeur au bout d'un
câble d'acier
ici on se balance au dessus du vide
comme un verre au bout de son hameçon
la vie n'a pas de prix pour un peu d'or
[Musique]
c'est pas une histoire facile ici mon
gars on a commencé avec le coeur et le
courage comme 10 des paysans voient la
couleur de cette terre dont cinq mètres
on aura trouvé 100 tonnes d'or c'est ma
prévision
elle est réelle et certaine j'ai les
planches je sais ce que je fais le
problème ici au brésil tu vois rêve
c'est que les riches ne veulent pas voir
les pauvres évoluer l'entreprise qui
vient s'installer ici l arroser pas mal
de politiciens de la région pour être
tranquille et faire passer des lois qui
l'arrangent
aujourd'hui je peux encore parlé mais au
moment où ça sera diffusée je serai
peut-être déjà mort c'est mon rêve c'est
ma vie ici tout ce que j'ai à dire
[Musique]
mon
à l'étagé du dessus dans la cuisine donc
j'ai eu envie de faire revenir les
souvenirs de chico sur la grande époque
quand la serra pelada grouillait de
milliers de chercheurs d'or j'ai besoin
de voir un 80 quand je suis arrivé à
serra pelada au bout de quinze jours
j'avais trouvé quatre cents kilos d'or
cette époque là j'avais 6 ans homme qui
travaillait pour moi j'amenais des
avions plein d'argent et si vieux on les
porte à l'épaule
on est vidé à même le sol sain tao comme
cette table tu vois et jeudi visait
chaque parent correspondait à la
participation de chacun on était une
vraie fratrie aujourd'hui les habitants
de serra pelada sont moins respectés que
les chiens
[Musique]
du jour où le gouvernement a fermé la
mine
chico a perdu tout l'argent qu'ils
avaient réinvesti dans ces trous obligé
même de vendre cette dent en or pour
manger mais la roue finit toujours par
tourner une sorcière lui a prédit qu'
vers la cinquantaine il deviendrait
riches
il a aujourd'hui 59 ans mais ne perd pas
l'espoir toujours prêt à s'en remettre à
sa bonne fortune
une poussière d'or une petite paillettes
que tu offres à la mine et tu trouveras
une grosse pépite
c'est la légende du chercheur d'or mais
c'est la vérité
[Musique]
la vérité à moi c'est que le voyage ne
s'arrête jamais j'ai abandonné chico à
son tunnel est au bout du mien j'ai
retrouvé le rail de la vie un train de
passagers cette fois la mine de fer l'a
mis en place pour se donner bonne figure
auprès de la population locale mais en
amazonie quand on voyage c'est souvent
parce qu'on est contraint de suivre le
mouvement pour se trouver enfin une
place à soi pouvoir nourrir sa famille
ailleurs qu en route et rêver enfin en
paix
[Musique]
un arrêt en plein nulle part pour
graille et c'est au moment où on échange
à quelques billets contre une plâtrée
que je me suis finalement décidé à
rencontrer notre espèce de pionnier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en suivant la course des vautours
j'ai atterri sur un ranch j'avais envie
de savoir comment on en était arrivé à
laissé la porte grande ouverte sur cette
terre qu l amazonie et qui autrefois
étaient recouvertes d'arbres
car ici on marque le cul des vaches et
on déforeste pour montrer que tout cela
est bien à swat
vingt-cinq mille hectares vingt mille
têtes de bétail le patron d'un ranch est
toujours celui qui regarde et en
amazonie
souvent un blanc sur la déforestation
il avait son explication
[Musique]
si un jour il faut replanter les arbres
qu'on a coupé on sera obligés de
relâcher des deux ça n'a pas de sens non
le vrai problème c'est les sans terre
ils ne produisent rien nous cause
beaucoup de soucis et détruisent nos
propriétés pour soi-disant survivre la
réalité se font de l'argent sur nos
terres qu'ils revendent l'amazonie est
un rapport de force permanent hommes et
boeufs patrons et ouvriers propriétaire
des sans terre ont ce roue de coups on
se traîne dans la boue dans le seul but
de posséder et on pose des barrières des
clôtures pour délimiter son territoire
premier arrivé premier servi
[Musique]
d'où je viens ce n'est guère mieux
d'autant qu'on mange des boeufs et qu'on
utilise le faire le steak de nos
assiettes
les barreaux de nos prisons viennent
parfois du coeur de l'amazonie bien
difficile donc d'être juge et partie
il faudrait s'arrêter et réfléchir mais
les hommes font tourner le monde de plus
en plus vite
ce soir là j'ai décidé de poursuivre mon
itinérance par la route en quête
d'hommes senteurs pour avoir leur
version
et comme je n'avais pas de cheval j'ai
fait du stop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la nuit est tombée et on s'est perdus
[Musique]
je me suis réveillé la tête dans un sac
de manioc convaincu d'être finalement
tombé sur ce que je cherchais des hommes
sans terre qui s'appropriait un bout
d'os ranch c'était en fait des ancêtres
d'esclaves qui par le passé s'était
enfui des plantations pour s'occuper
d'une terre enfin à elle c'était il ya
longtemps et le temps donne des droits
sur la terre
nous considérons pas comme des sans
terre cherche pas à s'approprier un
terrain on veut juste qu'on ne nous
prennent pas ce qu'on a déjà eu du mal à
avoir nous mettre dehors à cause du
projet de base spatiale de lancement de
satellites
le gouvernement dit que c'est le plus
grand projet de développement du brésil
et nous on serait le plus gros frein à
ce projet mais pour moi résister c'est
lutter pour la dignité de mon peuple
il faut que tu te souviennes
[Musique]
la côte pour fin de voyage sao luiz et
son port
on y charger minerai à destination du
monde mon voyage avait commencé au pied
d'un trou les pieds dans la boue
il se terminait les yeux dans l'eau au
bout d'un quai et dans une dernière
danse
le faire valider par tonne entière sans
que personne ne puisse arrêter la
musique
[Musique]
j'ai eu envie d'aller profiter de la
ville de são luis de ses ruelles calme
marc était enfin et puis réfléchir
[Musique]